maths news we all love maths news right
so recently uh the able prize was
announced the abel prize is like the
nobel prize for mathematics so the
winner of this year's abel prize was uh
andre semer adi he's a hungarian
mathematician it's in recognition of a
career in mathematics and so for that he
has won
six million norwegian kroner that's
about one million dollars so for this
video and we always like to attach a
number to a video we're going to use the
number six million
the prize itself only started in 2003
but it's now kind of being seen as the
mathematics
nobel prize there was a nobel prize
there was a prize called the fields
medal
for mathematics which has been around
much longer there's the fields medal
which is really for young mathematicians
young mathematicians for us is under 40.
the able prize has no restriction like
that so it is more directly comparable
to the nobel prizes there's a fair
amount of publicity about it so it's
awarded in norway and some people fly
over for the ceremony there is no nobel
prize for mathematics there are some
stories about that and maybe i'll save
those to the end i'd like to end with an
anti-climax
so surname is semi-ready
s-z-e-m-e-r-e-d-i
um first name andre and andre um so
quite difficult to just pronounce like
many of the hungarian mathematicians
it's he's now in his in his 70s he's
published over 200 papers in a wide
variety of areas
in particular
lots of applications to graph theory and
applications to number theory and
including computer science to sorting
sorting algorithms but i'll talk today
about um
some of the applications in some to what
sounds a bit like number theory to do
with counting sets
of integers with certain properties so
i'm going to talk about
what's now called semradi's theorem that
used to be called the erdish turan
conjecture
which stood for 30 or 40 years and
because of the importance of the result
and the ways in which seminary proved it
the result has now taken on his name
one of his big theorems is now named
after some 80s so it's summer aides
theorem and it's about finding structure
in randomness so this is what we're
going to look at we're going to look at
something called arithmetic progressions
integers we're thinking about patterns
within integers so suppose i take a list
of integers i'll try and list
a few of them one six seven
there i've chosen six numbers but
unfortunately what's happened
is i've chosen them in such a way that 1
4 7 10
form what's called an arithmetic
progression
so it's a progression where the gaps
between the numbers is the same at every
step what we're going to try and do now
is we're going to try to choose the
numbers and avoid these patterns
so i'm going to choose some numbers
between 1 and 15. let's focus just on
patterns of length 3. so a pattern where
you've got a number
a second number and a third number where
the gap between the first and second
number is the same as the gap between
the second and third number like one
four seven or four seven ten so i'll
choose one i'll choose two now i can't
choose three because i'd have a pattern
immediately so let's choose four i can't
choose six because then we'd have two
four six which forms a pattern of three
in a row with the same difference so i
can't have six can i have five yes i'll
have five i can't have seven because one
four seven would be a pattern
and i'm starting to struggle to find
numbers i have to start going to eight
so i go to eight if i managed it oh no
i've already failed
i tried but i failed because two five
eight was a pattern it's actually quite
difficult to choose numbers without
avoiding certain patterns we're going to
try and move towards what samurai's
theorem says let's try and avoid three
so let's choose k
that's going to be equal to three that's
the the length of a sequence i'm going
to try and avoid
and
the rules are we're gonna have to choose
numbers from the list one two
three
up to some enormous number n
very large number n for example a
million so we're going to try and choose
numbers from one to a million just like
we chose numbers before we're going to
try and avoid having any three somewhere
which i've got a common difference
now obviously i'm not going to do that
now because there are far too many
numbers to choose from but what samurai
said is actually it's surprisingly few
numbers that you're allowed to choose
before you're forced to have a pattern
one way to describe this theorem is i
ask
you
for some percentage
and you give me
one percent
one percent is going to be how what
percentage of the numbers i'm going to
offer you that you're going to have to
choose let's go more advanced let's
choose k is 4. that means we're gonna
have to try and avoid having four
numbers in the sequence somewhere which
have all got a common difference
like 10 20 30 40
or 100 1900
2800 i could also put in 45
55 and 60 and i'd have messed up
and what severity said
so here's summary he comes along and he
gives us some completely insanely large
number
which might be 10 to the
10 to the 10th
this is going to be how many numbers
like you get to choose from so i'm not
going to give you the exercise you've
got to choose one percent of the numbers
from this list and try and avoid a
sequence of length four you won't manage
it some radius cleverly his his theorem
says that if you chose any percentage
and any k he can come back with a number
that says if you choose even one percent
of those numbers
you will have accidentally at some point
chosen four numbers in your list
with a with a common difference between
them so you probably say this is all
very well but one percent maybe was too
many and k was four that was quite a
short list to try and avoid actually
even if you'd give me a ludicrous
percentage if you give me a tiny
percentage nor point nor nor one percent
so at the end of this game i'm going to
give you a list of numbers and you can
choose naught point nor one percent of
them that's very very few of them and
even if we then chosen k to be something
else something much larger say k is a
hundred
okay it's a hundred means all you've got
to do is avoid having a hundred numbers
where the common difference is the same
all the way along now you'd think that
was really easy to avoid you'd think you
could manage that somebody says okay
give me your give me your num percentage
give me okay he'll go away come back
from his theorem
and he's going to give you another
number on the end his number's going to
be
even larger
so i'm completely insane number but it's
a number you won't manage to avoid
this what seems like a very unlikely
thing and this is true for any
percentage and for any k did samurai
come up with an equation that you could
plug that number into and that number
into to give you that number is there an
equation if only
no so
a lot of the results in this in this
area
have this
strangely non-constructive proof to them
so the actual proof itself doesn't even
give you the number it purely says there
must be a number you said if i came up
with any percentage and any k
samaritan would come back to me with a
number are you now saying samurai
actually he couldn't give me a number he
could just tell me a number exists he
could tell your number exists
there have been results since since his
work
for which people have managed to
to give enough a band on this number in
which case they could now give you a
number the one thing that troubles me
here is
there are an infinite number of numbers
aren't there yeah so
i could have told you that no matter
what you put there and no matter what
you put there there'll be a number there
eventually because there are an infinite
number of numbers that could go there so
so why has samurai been clever so
suppose you took all the numbers suppose
we go one
two three now this list goes on forever
so this is all the integers you know
what seven radius result tells us is
that
if you gave me a percentage so again
let's choose a percentage this time i'll
go for something slightly bigger
4.01
if you if i ask you to choose a list of
integers
it's going to be very long this because
you've got to choose 0.01 percent you're
still going to have to choose infinitely
many but you can choose about 1 in 10
000 of all the numbers
what summaries result tells you is you
are going to accidentally
create progressions lists
of all lengths
not just length 4 and 100 but any
possible length will appear in your list
if all you did was choose numbers to
arrange to choose about 10 000 of them
so what i really liked about this though
is that this theorem was used to prove
another result
pretty much similar but about prime
numbers now the prime numbers are
actually quite rare they're
unpredictable and rare so they have
density zero now you can't use some ads
theorem to prove uh the same result with
the prime numbers because some 80's
theorem was about things that had
greater than zero density
but you could use this theorem in the
proof
of this statement the prime numbers
have arithmetic progressions
so
let's take the list of prime numbers we
know the prime numbers they're two and
three and five they go on forever
they're rare and unpredictable but still
you can find sequences like the
arithmetic progressions
of length 100 with one million
whatever you want and that is
surprising there is structure in the
randomness of the prime numbers an
arithmetic sequence in the prime numbers
uh let's pick i'm going to start with
five
that's prime number and i'm going to add
on 6. that's 11.
i'm going to add on 6 again
that is
oh 17 that's a prime number add on 6
again
that's 23
add on 6 again
that's 29
and that is a
arithmetic progression of length 5
just using prime numbers the common
difference is 6.
in this case
they are called sexy primes we're going
to talk about that aren't we
now the theorem doesn't guarantee
what the common difference will be you
can't specify it it doesn't tell you
where to start it it doesn't even tell
you how to find them but i what i can
guarantee you is that i can give you a
progression of any length
i can give you a progression of length
a million a billion even imagine but you
can't tell me what the gap is i can't
tell you what the gap is but imagine a
progression
of a billion just using prime numbers
where they have the common difference
the same all the way through
and that's there and that is in there
and that is guaranteed to be in there i
can't tell you what it is but it's
guaranteed to be in there
who figured that out
who figured ah who figured that out oh
the prime number version sorry
that was figured out by a cambridge
mathematician called tim gowers and he's
around here somewhere he'll be in one of
these offices really yeah yeah well
let's go
is this just
you know crosswords and sudoku is this
just mathematicians being
unimaginably clever or is there a
practical reason for samurai to do this
so some of the some of the final results
like this result it's not obvious this
has any particular applications um but
what's definitely true is that in order
to get to these results that samaritan
himself proved particularly one famous
result called the cemeteries what's
called summery's regularity lemma
which has now been used in a number of
different areas of maths not just this
this this fairly small area of trying to
count progressions that's particularly
one of the reasons why
why he's been recognized um
not just because he's done one one big
thing but he's done a number of big
things and even to prove those big
things he's developed a whole new area
of theory which has been used by many
people since him so there is no nobel
prize for maths now the story that is
told in maths departments around the
world is that
nobel
he didn't give a nobel prize for
mathematics or didn't set one up because
he hated mathematicians and because his
wife ran off with a mathematician
and that's the story that he's told in
math departments all over
the only problem is
he wasn't married
and it's not true it's not true uh he i
guess though nobel
didn't appreciate mathematics enough to
give it a prize uh he was interested in
physics and chemistry and there isn't a
nobel prize for biology either so it's
it's that reason it's less exciting i
told you i wanted to end with an
anti-climax